sombra hidratación y poca ropa son los
remedios que los europeos se encuentran
en medio de la ola de calor que afecta
al viejo continente en el reino unido
los termómetros marcaron el día más
cálido del año hasta ahora con 34 grados
centígrados allí y centenares de
personas salieron a las playas para
mitigar los efectos de las altas
temperaturas
nacionales y turistas son conscientes de
las causas de este fenómeno
metereológico and found servers navin
services training soy de chipre y ahora
en chipre está lloviendo y estoy en
londres y estoy sirviendo aquí así que
algo debe cambiar necesitamos tomar
precauciones sobre el cambio climático
más temprano que tarde porque sin duda
es preocupante para todos nosotros ahora
lo estamos disfrutando pero a largo
plazo podríamos sacrificarnos por un
micrófono de might sacrifice en francia
se vive en temperaturas récord en
burdeos los 39 grados reinantes hacen
que las sombras y las fuentes adquieran
un valor incalculable los parques
albergan personas semidesnudas que
disfrutan de la frescura de esos sitios
y durante el día voy a los museos a los
jardines a todos los centros comerciales
cualquier cosa para refrescar mis ideas
y me tomo mi tiempo para no pasar
demasiado calor pero por la noche donde
estoy es bajo techo y es insoportable
en españa las temperaturas han alcanzado
los 43 grados lo que hace que aumenta el
riesgo de incendios forestales
cataluña ha perdido más de 500 hectáreas
de bosque producto de las llamas cerca
de baldomar en casi todo el país el
riesgo de fuego es extremo según la
agencia estatal de metereología